let's bring in Tony Clark who went
toe-to-toe with the Commissioner for the
last couple of months on this Tony how
you feeling today as we get training
camps started or restarted good morning
Dan excited excited to have the guys
back in camp even though we have the
challenges that we do but excited to
have have the guys back doing what they
love doing what did you make of the
Commissioner validating what I had been
told that once they got settled on 60
with ownership that they weren't budging
off 60 games that's the decision that
they decided to make I think throughout
the process we highlighted the interest
in playing as many games as possible
from start to finish and and maintain
that position but it appears that their
interests were a little bit different
particularly as things progressed toward
toward where we landed what was the main
reason he took this long to get
something done well I think that the
interests from the other side appeared
to be that 60 games despite having made
the the proposals that they made earlier
in other words from start to finish
there was an interest in a certain
amount of money being spent against the
backdrop of of a particular number of
games being played so that conversation
spanned the two months that it did in
the fashion that it did I know that
that's that's a large part of what we
focused on was the back and forth and
having covered strikes and lockouts I
never worried about the negotiation so I
figured they would always get settled
it's not a pretty picture for either
side here but I worry about the safety
guidelines here Tony just being able to
play baseball you know everybody was
talking about the money and games and I
said can we actually pull this off how
confident are you
we'll have sixty sixty game season well
to be to be clear the other side was the
one talking about money we ended up as
part of that color conversation our
focus was the health and safety to your
point guys recognize that we're in
unprecedented times and and the the
protocols are going to be in processes
are going to be much different than
anything they've experienced before and
so it is challenging and everybody
got a role to play not just on the field
off the field and guys understand that
so we're we're hopeful particularly as
guys arrived into camp as we speak that
they can get comfortable with those
protocols that their families and all
involved can be comfortable with those
protocols and then do our best to to
make sure that we're able to to keep
everyone healthy as healthy as possible
and play as many games as possible do
you take it personally what happens with
the negotiations with the commissioner
no no at the end of our day our
responsibility my responsibility is
fairly simple and that is making sure to
protect and advance the interests of our
our players of our members so no it
doesn't doesn't end up being personal
obviously as a player a former player I
guess I should say my love and passion
for the game remains so that's that's
not going to change but our role and
responsibility is pretty consistent
started but you know these players are
gonna took this personally and that next
collective bargaining agreement Tony
it's gonna be it's gonna be ugly
there there there are a lot of
predictions and and and a lot of
open-ended questions at this point we'll
have to see how things progress but I
think as much as anything when the game
is attacked to when when players are
attacked when their Union is attacked
sure there are our personal interests
that become a part of that conversation
but we're we're still a little ways away
guys his eyes were opened I think it was
a bit of a wake-up call these last
couple of months with the challenges
that we needed to work through but we'll
see how those negotiations go here
moving forward what about black lives
matter with the players anything planned
well needless to say it's a very
personal issue for me it's a very
personal issue for our players and so
there is nothing scheduled at this point
in time but there is a lot of dialogue
that is happening behind the scenes both
with our players and eventually as we
anticipate with with the league as well
we were talking base
Paul and Don Mattingly was on the first
hour and it's amazing how you guys
recall the inning or the pitch it's
amazing
whether it's John Smoltz talking about
facing bonds or it's Mattingly facing
Roger Clemens and he's telling you the
count the pitches like everything do you
have a moment because people should know
that you play baseball for a long period
of time but is there one of those
moments where you you kind of go back to
and you it was a it was a great magical
moment for you well I have a number of
them it's it's hard to highlight warm
but I'll offer this initial one which
was my first big league game so as you
mentioned I was fortunate to have played
over the course of 15 seasons and in the
big leagues and a number of years in the
minor leagues and had aspirations even
when I was younger of playing
professional basketball but my very
first day in the big leagues and playing
for Sparky Anderson and looking to my
left and seeing Lou Whitaker and and and
Alan Trammell and looking to my right
and seeing cessful fielder who took me
under his wing when I got there that
very first game and each of the advanced
struck out my first at-bat I struck out
my Santa bat hit a ground ball to second
my my third at-bat and was excited to
actually have put the ball in play and
then my fourth had bad got my first hit
off over Leon Tavares and got my second
at-bat my our second hit in my fifth
at-bat off a Jose Mesa and you'll
probably recall as as a baseball fan
yourself that in the mid mid 90s those
those Cleveland Indians teams were were
something special so that that very
first game and and having an opportunity
to step on the field where we're a
number of the greats did including Al
Kaline who was somebody I leaned on as
well it's just it's something that I'll
never forget
well you probably got some bullet holes
there maybe bleeding a little bit from
those negotiations but I know you you
live to see another day hopefully we get
60 games season I'm not as optimistic
but you know I'm hopeful but
maybe we get it and I wish you luck Tony
because I know what those negotiations
are gonna be like I you know you're
gonna be rough I'm gonna be rough I
appreciate it there's there's a lot that
we're gonna have to work through a lot
of concerns with respect to where our
game is and where it's going so uh we'll
be diligent and we'll we'll grind
through it thank you Tony
thank you that's Tony Clark the
executive director of the Baseball
Players Association